not even close to a year we have the R
phone8 Pro with us and it is as Sleek as
ever especially with its anime Vision on
the back it's got a pretty sick set of
specs and features as always with Armory
crate being the Beating Heart of the
phone with that we'll be running through
our gaming Gauntlet of honai stario
genin impact call duty mobile with a
backbone and pubg mobile of course this
comes with the AER cooler but for the
sake of fairness the other phones we're
going to see how far we can bring it on
its Dynamic mode performance- wise the
Asus RG Phone 8 Pro that we have is
running Snapdragon H gen 3 for its
processor and adrenal 750 for its GPU 24
gigs of RAM 1 terab of storage and
everything plays out only 6.78 in
flexible ltpo AMOLED
hdr10 165 HZ display and it has a 5,500
M battery before I run the test let's do
a baseline of the temperatures on the
front and
back so at the front we are at
25.5 25.6 not too bad nothing to crazy
and the back starting with the camera
module 25.4 it's about the same as the
front all right so we're going to be
starting off with our first game honai
stario now the we honai stario we
currently 100% battery and this info box
can be accessed by game gen by pulling
down here and we also Dynamic mode and
real time info right there so with that
let's check our settings all right so
everything things are very high we at 60
FPS and this is what we are working with
today all right so that's settled let's
get into the simulated universe but
before that let's just check out how
things are currently just everything's
at 61 FPS it's running really smooth
let's try switching Up
characters hardly any F drops even if I
switch it around the camera I mean and
yeah we we're doing pretty all right so
far okay let's just get into it
all right now that we're here let's get
into some combat let's just break this
thing real quick but oh there's a f drob
for some
reason r on the
49 in here um it's going back up to 61
let's bounce real
quick Ni No wish there all right let's
do everything normal speed just for
now all right so far so good and swing
there we
go just all right let's
bounce okay so let's go with an Al what
are you waiting for let's see how the
phone handles it the customer is and for
me to portray theame well you got to
make itth my it's still hanging at 361
on Dynamic mode this is doing pretty
good all pretty good this thing really
amazing so
far all right
cool
try welcome all right let's go with glal
Cas check out this
awesome
all right let's get shields up and the
thing about jaar's Alti for those that
don't know honestly one of this his Al
is one of the more graphically intensive
one so you'll see how well this phone
does never oh only like two frames which
is amazing I have not seen that in a
while this these are some really good
numbers with the RG 48
Pro aome this is our chair all right
Hur R what are you waiting for all right
let's thre it out
Al very well so far let's get those
shoes
up there we go any drops nothing at all
this one is crazy it's it's doing so
well my Lord right get that and
Swing Swing
Swing try that again we're actually
really close this
bounce and we're done nice all right so
with that let's check temperatures on
the phone honestly I
am I am surprised but not really that R
has put out such a great phone oh my God
we only at 35ish De C we're barely
hitting like our normal temperature 37
at the bottom 38 right there if you can
see that 36 35 and you get around to the
lower region of the phone it does feel a
little warm but honestly like I I felt
much worse before on other gaming phones
and let's check the back from the camera
module we're cing at
34 and on the side
35 36
37.3 so the chips are at the bottom of
the device with 3.5 for for hongry Star
real is quite crazy because honestly it
doesn't feel that warm in hand and it's
just that this phone is so really good
to grip I will say that the sides do get
a bit warm but at the same time also
it's not exactly super noticeable unless
you're really sensitive but the main
thing is that we are currently at 96%
battery you taking only 4% of battery
after playing like one round of the
simul universe so with that let's move
on to our next game genin
impact all right we are H off the heels
of honkai staro let's check out our
temperatures before getting the Gent
impact let's check the front and
currently 96% battery so
28.1 and as we go down still 28 28.3
28.4 that's the highest we've seen so
far after one game and let's check the
back the camera module 27.6
28.6
28.9 all right we're doing pretty damn
good nothing's really hitting 30 so safe
to say this one has cooled down quite a
bit in a very short period of time and
as you can see 96% battery right here
that's how we can view our battery as
well on top of having animations here so
with that let's get into genin impact
okay so now the weing genin impact we're
currently 95% battery let us check out
our set things real quick but look at
that this game looks beautiful full on
the phone 61 FPS and also I believe we
are on Dynamic Mode still yes we are all
right let's check some things real quick
all right everything is on the highest
we're at 60 FPS can't go more than that
and let's see all right here we go
everything is set to the highest and
let's just take a look at how our
characters fair if I move the camera out
no frame stering nothing no frame rate
drops let's switch up
characters no issues whatsoever so we're
doing pretty good it's running hella
smooth and let's just run through in his
City real quick and see whether we we
have any major framy drops or frame
suing right oh there's a little frame Su
right there but was so quick that FPS
count didn't we pick it up but let's
keep
moving
look really good honestly it plays out
very very smoothly when of you guys
would he to like hold this in your hands
and play with it damn this thing is O
okay I can't wait to see how this thing
handles
combat oo okay little frames out there
as well but honestly nothing game
breaking or anything all right I think
we're doing pretty good let's go do some
exploration and combat
all right here we
go okay my
bad let's keep
going right very very smooth Let's do an
Alti once that's
available I can't get out of the way but
Alti there we
go all right let's
go all right so far so good obviously I
did make a lot of good calls here but
the thing is this one is doing really
well oh there's more my bad I forgot
about the second wave right
Alti let's get
you here we
go and they're all down yeah no issues
with combat and exploration whatsoever
all right so uh with that let us get
into the spiral abyss and GA everyone up
as usual and Alti time for
Retribution very
well run run run run run me take care of
the Archer real
quick come on all right one time he all
clumped up together oh okay that was bad
we is timed but we are doing okay nicely
done all right let's get
him okay that's one side done let's go
to the other side
now 92% battery I think I went down by
one but so far so good we're doing very
well all
right let's get him let's get him let's
get him that's one
down all right you but you can't hide
you're
and we're good let's just do one more
round all right
Alti all right so one more guy down
let's all through this real
quick and I have to say the speakers are
actually doing really
good right one more
guy I think that just seal the deal yes
it
does doing very very well right
now
okay Dodge that let's get
in and we are done all right so we're at
91% battery right now and again no FPS
drops nothing no frame stuttering this
thing is running very very smoothly
let's check out temperatures real quick
so at the front
33.8 33.9 34 nothing too drastic but
okay 37 that's like the highest we've
seen so far but even if that's nothing
to write home about that's actually
relatively cool compared to a lot of
other phones that we have tested before
let's check the back
94.3 94 this place is pretty dead and
the camera module
34.9 we're doing very good honestly real
fuel bias the phone is still very very
comfortable to touch and grip on and
again I have to say speakers are really
good size is good as well I've got a
good grip in my hands and yeah that is
yeah this thing is crazy this thing is
from what I can tell this is one of the
best phones we've worked with so far
honestly R does not disappoint with the
performance on the Rog phones and this
channel is supported by Brands to help
us improve our content and keep us going
so stick around for this sponsored
message here geek culture we've tested
plenty of chairs but secret La gaming
chairs remain one of our favorites
whether it's for work or play they feel
great to lean back against with the
ergonomic features offering support for
the whole body from the head and back to
the arms and even something for your but
but this mix of Forman function helps
the Titan Evo 2022 deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out
s.co all right now with G impact over we
are going to be playing with C mobile
but before that let's check temperatures
real quick 35.5
32.7
33.2 all right it has cooled down quite
a bit on no so we are currently 90%
battery right now let's check the
back anyim visions just really cool 33.6
32.8 33.1 and yeah this thing has cooled
down quite
quickly wow okay it's really good really
great tho management so right now let's
get into call mobile but with the
backbone of course one thing to note
with the RG Phone 8 Pro when using the
backbone is that the USBC slot is on the
bottom left of the phone and correct me
if I'm wrong this is the same with the
RG phone 7s it'll kind of feel balance
because you know physics right all right
let's put it in
there and spread this out just like that
and we are set so let's get into Call of
Duty
mobile all right now that we're in game
let's check our settings real
quick and go to audio and graphics and
we are on we kind of good Ultra okay
Ultra frame rate and Max but we can't do
that so um like most V players we're
going to go with ultra going to change
things up a little bit here so Ultra
frame rate cuz you know more frames uh
anti aing is on Battle Royale mode this
is what we're going with here and let's
do a Shader
preload for good
measure so far still 61 FPS I mean
honestly this is Call of Duty mobile and
also we're playing this on the dynamic
mode and we time and put at the top here
so currently 89% battery and the phone's
at 28° C 61 FPS I believe I do not have
any teammates joining me for this one so
we make
do look at that m is looking really good
in this
lighting let's see where I'm going to
jump off let's go to bus
station okay never mind I kind of went
off too early or not really
no all right here we
go all right going
down
get straight for the
basement they're
upstairs okay that's just a bot but
never mind let's get
him the revive flight will arri in
minut nice I can do
that all right this the second one down
so far no major frame rate drops no
frame start doing nothing and we have
taken out 1% of the battery so we're at
88% right now at the start of the
match let's focus on getting more
stuff oh and the other thing to not is
that the speakers are in the sides here
and here of the phone so be mindful of
that if you're if you're planning on
playing with a controll like the
backbone obviously I recommend you
either making the game no making the
game pretty loud or you know obviously
just using your wireless earbuds or if
you have wide earphones there's a 3.5 M
Jack here so at least on the backbone so
you have those options for
audio right in front of
me out
[Music]
incom all right two dogs are down
it just means the guys inside here
still O Okay that was kind of
close all right there one guy
down this guys so far we're about 14
minutes into the match 15 minutes into
the match and we are at 85% battery we
started at 90 so that's not too bad
honestly and the frame rate has not
dropped at all I mean we are running a
snam Dragon H gen three and there's 24
gigs of RAM on this thing so honestly no
isues if this thing can handle honkai
and genin oh my gosh this and pubg no
issues definitely
all right come on
reloading all right we have eight more
people to
[Applause]
kill all
right the morons two teams left getting
close to uh how how many more people is
that oh yeah two more
people he should be really close there
he
is there we go and that's the last guy
with that let's check out temperatures
real
quick right thank you
backb all right in the front where we
have ended the game at 83% let's check
the front
34° still honestly pretty good 35.8
unless you go low it'll get higher okay
not exactly
no 35.1 all right not too bad let's
check the
back 33.7 33.5
34 35.2 36 all right actually we're
doing pretty well the info panel here
shows that the internal temperatures at
about 37° C
but on the outside it doesn't feel like
that at all it's still very comfortable
to hold here so I think even if you use
something like the backbone you won't
have any issues when it comes to thero
management on this thing and with that
let's get into our final game pubg
mobile so we're down to pubg mobile
let's check temperates before we
start yeah
33 degre get 33 Okay this thing actually
does handle thermals very well this
thing has cooled down pretty quickly I
mean we just got off called Mobile in
currently 83% let's check the back 31.7
the camera module 32.6
33.1 and yeah all right yeah this thing
actually has cooled down quite a bit and
with that let's just get into pubg
Mobile which will be playing with the
air triggers all right so now that we
the main page let's check our settings
real
quick all right graphics and audio
smooth Graphics as always 90 FPS this
thing can do that 4 8 thing and I think
we're good but and everything have been
set up let's check Jame Game Genie real
quick and we'll go over to air triggers
and yep everything set up nicely for me
so with that let's just get into a match
yeah currently 80% battery right now and
let's see how well we do this match I I
mean honestly look at that we 90ish FPS
oh that's interesting it's dropping to
like 83 that's the lowest I've seen
that's like the most drastic drop I've
seen I think besides genin good luck
matate
oh no okay wait I need I need switch
things
around it's not jumping okay we're
finally
Jumping All right so we're moving right
now pretty pretty smooth flight
down two of
us okay I'm just unfold this guy move
[Applause]
on
right let's slowly go
down to the left
side
all right there we
go not sure if she wants to get out or
not
but all right first kill
nice so far as we are driving to find
one of our mates um I haven't seen any
drastic family drop
it's still at a very steady 90 FPS right
now and honestly it doesn't feel too hot
it shows internal temperature at 41° cus
wow it doesn't feel like it's 40 it
doesn't even feel like it's at 35 right
now to be quite honest it's working out
pretty much okay on my end at least in
terms of like real feel on hands so
besides that I think we're doing a or
and also
we%
get us into adequate enough
cover can't see the muzzle
flash I don't really see
them at all
oh damn it where where was he firing
from oh I see they were on the
church ah okay but yeah um obviously
that's not enough
so unfortunately I'll be leaving this
game
and we be playing another
game all right we're starting a second
game of pubg mobile we're currently at
76% battery
and H you know
what yeah while we're waiting for for
the game to load let's just check our
temperatures real quick
cuz it does feel kind of hot right now
37.9 38.1 oh okay this actually the
highest 40
41 yeah this is the highest we've gotten
and I'm just surprised it wasn't on
genin oh
okay wait hold hold on one second don't
tell
me okay oh no we' been on Dynamic mode
wow okay I thought we on X mode but we'
been on Dynamic mode and wow okay okay
okay okay I see
interesting and right about
no all
right pretty consumables I need
consumables okay
brother hold
[Applause]
on getting in there currently we at 42°
C we at 75% battery right
now right let's get
in going to go straight for these
buildings right
here
at least I have something with
me oh that was a that's a level two
backpack oh oh God damn it oh on the
roof again oh my gosh I keep getting
screwed by guys on the roof as you can
see the the game runs pretty fine it's
just that uh I'm I'm pretty down on my
luck today so I guess we can call it
quits on that so with that let's
just check Final
temperatures so it's kind of
embarrassing but never mind uh 3.7 39.6
it is getting pretty hot down here
41.6 is the highest I believe 40 41.3
all right that's it's it's a funny thing
because genin and hongkai never got this
H but for pupg does which is interesting
and we're not running on X mode or
anything we're running on Dynamic mode
all right back 38.1 3.6 38.9
40.4
40 all
right okay so with that I think we can
head on to our final thoughts the RG 48
Pro is exactly what You' expect from
Asus Rog Solid thermal management great
battery life sweet accessories which of
course we didn't use in this test to be
fair to the rest of the phones we try
out and above all amazing performance
with the Snapdragon 8 gen 3 and 24 G of
ram which just blows away most of the
competition in the gaming phone space
honai and genin impact had little to no
frame rate drops or stuttering and C
mobile and pubg mobile played smooth as
heck with the only surprise being that
pubg mobile ran the hotest at 41° celsus
during the match something that genin
and honai are usually capable of but not
with this phone overall the RG 48 Pro is
a demon in its class offering on Bridal
power with amazing thermal management so
would you be getting the RG 48 Pro let
me know in the comment section below
leave your questions there too if you
have any and we'll do our best to get to
them if you like what we do make sure to
follow us on all of our socials right
here because we upload stuff every day
and maybe leave a like and hit that
subscribe button it goes a long way this
is in have a great week and if you want
to see more stuff check this
[Music]
out
oh